my contract was up in 2019 with the
Steelers and uh kind of took it upon
myself and I just knew how the market go
you know the new things with players and
teams they pay one receiver then they
hype up the other one it's like you know
I mean it's a it's a competitiveness
upon its players because it's a alpha
game you know what I mean it's
a war game you know what I mean who's
the best player it's a so when you come
conducive to all those things you know
you just
but in 2019 when you signed that
contract with the Steelers
icon in 2017 it was a five-year deal for
73 million okay exactly I played 2017
2018 after the season of 2018 uh
understanding what it what it meant to
be marginalized to be uh
to be you know what I mean just to be
controlled and you know what I mean
after that time you know I just think I
got smart and was like
you know I wanted out the contract you
know what I mean like so I kind of made
a Twitter post and you know I mean I was
kind of I was smarter than God what I
wanted and I was able to go to the
Oakland and it was adding more money
like you said into the contract which
never had been done but obviously the
NFL is controlled by who the owners the
media is ran by the owners and uh Drew
rosenhouse with my agent at the time in
2019. and um
you know Jew is uh he worked you know
for the players but he's mostly worked
for the NFL you know at the end of the
day players are not gonna always play so
he got a longer relationship with the
NFL so obviously I was able to get
myself out of the contract which is
almost impossible to do in the NFL then
I went and got more money than I get
over there the Raiders and I'm like
well it really ain't about the money
because if I want to be great and have a
chance to win it you know I need to be
around people that are winners you know
with the right winning fortitude so I
kind of worked up myself out of that
situation man look at the best with the
media player how things went down
and um that year I was played one game
with the Pats you know I only played one
year I met Tom that year for the first
time and I think you know he fell in
love with you know my work ethic and uh
my mental fortitude of being able to you
know be a professional pick up the plays
be accountable and do all the things
that take the bill intangible Dependable
wide receiver and I played one game I
think we played down here in Miami I had
a big game remember the team that day
yeah and [ __ ] the next week you know
what I'm saying I was off the team and
uh what happened you played one game man
I tell you what happened one game that
year they paid me like five million but
like I said you know I had done
outsmarted distillers I went to the
Raiders and had some mishap words like
man I know ain't gonna win I just went
out Mark Davis man is not about the
money I got respect for you I just now
you know I can't be the best player for
you here man that's Al's son of course
it's the owner right now yeah so now he
decided like hey I got you he let me
release me let me go I get picked up by
the uh Patriots I come here had the
biggest game you know I mean first game
and they'll go crazy and then the next
week I get infiltrated out the lead for
a per se a text so now I know I'm being
infiltrated because now if I played a
year with Tom Brady what do you think is
going to happen when I play with Tom
Brady I'm gonna have a lot of stats
with Stats come success will come
attention will come so now a god about
the name of uh darrenheitner you
probably know him local God I know
during course you know of course so now
it's the off season of that year now the
NFL is investigating me
I give them all my phones when they
investigate Tom Brady they don't take
his phones when Tom Brady need 15 days
off he get it when I need to cut days
off because I got [ __ ] I'm crazy if I
miss the media I'm on TV you know so
that's why I have problems with yeah
that's what I have problems with so it's
like
now I go to the Patriots and I get a
chance to have success but now the NFL
is ran by owners that's corrupt so what
do you think they do they set me up in
the media darrenheiter who is not even
my lawyer who worked with friends with
Drew Rosa house they let him accept the
suit on my behalf which is a girl that's
claiming sexual assault you see what I'm
saying a lawyer accepting a suit on my
behalf that is not even my lawyer so now
I fall victim to ruin my reputation
being embarrassed from going from being
the greatest player on a dominant place
to Cherry rice today manipulating my
position because I told you those moves
I made
so now I missed the whole year and I'm
dealing with people ruining my my
reputation
based on
me doing what business outsmarting them
now I'm in a lawsuit and my whole
reputation in the school right
so it's like yo I've been suppressed you
know I've been through stuff that it
wasn't true you know what I'm saying
I've been manipulated and
it's like still no it ain't even no
truth get out so like imagine a guy
who've been through all this to be great
and put itself through all this and get
in this moment and then get down like
that and when it's like you know then I
overcome all that right
because when they kick you to the side
they're supposed to be finished with you
I pay the people off go through all they
get it and then find my phones come back
and win the Super Bowl right
that's what happened I don't get a
congratulation for Tom Brady Tom Brady
deal with me like I'm a kid it's just
trying to take my money you know he get
already get paid from Tampa Bay you know
I paid for a million dollars in 2020.
you know you just said I make what 17 18
19 mil to do what I do so I show people
I could be humble it wasn't about you
know what I'm saying
so as I you know when I win the Super
Bowl I don't say oh congratulations to
Tom you call me after the game to
apologize about the video I saw about
you know what I mean hugging me and it's
not a bad thing Giselle is a great woman
man I got Virginia respect no she's
genuinely happy it's not you know I mean
I don't I don't like you said man we
love our principles I don't go I got my
own family I don't want no one girl I
don't you know I live on
you know real principles out here and I
stand on them
what is that you know I mean a lot of
things that go on that's not in the
media or not per seed or portrayed on my
behalf and it's always fun the wrong way
and it's like yo how long you gonna keep
poking the bear
you see what I'm saying John Brady my
friend Julio Jones He makes six million
guarantee he don't play no game
a b missed one game and my [ __ ]
deltoid ligament torn
now these guys investigate for me before
cover car and not investigated P they
tell me if your [ __ ] wrong you go to
Federal
all these guys [ __ ] got bad cars my
[ __ ] is official I showed them proving
it but it's like
you see what I'm saying this is the
trauma that I gotta continue to deal
with on a daily basis and I gotta come
and talk to people from a standpoint
that's just knowing me for what I do not
who I am because my Public Image has
been slated about who I am because it's
ran by the perpetrator media of people
that you know I mean they get paid to
make me look bad the news is bad you
know what I'm saying so you know to put
it in perspective you know what I mean
it's like Paul know you don't mean wrong
man I'm glad you're grateful to be here
I don't want to make you feel I don't
want to be here man I drove three hours
to be hit off I got my kids from school
set them up tell them I love them dog
jumped in the car Joe right here I went
home got some food and came right here
man so I don't take this as a for
granted I don't take this as no [ __ ]
time I'm just a guy who been through the
mud man I'm from Liberty City so I know
what it's like yeah government cheese
you know and I know what it's like uh
catch the metro bus I know what it's
like then I have none but I know what
it's like to work my way in the position
to get some I know what it like to have
integrity I went to Central Michigan and
never been there I walked on I earned my
scholarship I left school early
you know what I'm saying I play special
teams like uh Pittsburgh Steelers I was
a sixth round pick I earned my spot
ain't nobody put me in that position I
worked myself in that position but I
can't let people continue to step on my
image treat me bad old Tom Brady let you
stay in this house hey man I'm Antonio
Brown business is booming for real I'm a
wealthy guy I got homestead tax I take
care of my business I did the right
things in the NFL it's not a coincidence
everyone after the NFL's goal is broke
so I didn't know I didn't need Tom Brady
to play football I played because I
thought he was considerate and was my
friend was helping me play football not
that he was going to try to be my dad or
my big brother to tell me what I need to
do to be successful I think that's why
you came and got me to help me help you
be successful and I'm not standing in
that point where I'm you know I'm not
grateful for the relationship but
relationship to me has been on respect
where there's no respect is no respect
given
you know what I mean
we're not telling guys I'm hurting it's
a deltoid ligament if you got your
deltoid look at me as well rotate your
circle that's what rotate my ankle so
when I catch the ball I can't turn and
play you saw the text messages I put out
I texted the code I had a conversation
with Tom Brady about come play we gonna
get you the ball man and I had it I paid
this trainer a hundred thousand dollars
me and him got a mutual friend Jeff
Sofer billionaire guy right here in
South Florida of course you know of
course of course you know but it ain't
about what he got it ain't about what he
got it's about who he is Jeff sofa's a
real man billionaire God but he's a real
man what did sopher do for you bro I
don't need nobody to do for me I invest
money with so far I got my own money I'm
Antonio Brown the individual sir I don't
need no one to do nothing for me I'm
self-sufficient I told you the first
rule the law accept preservation I have
myself I don't need Tom Brady to let me
stay in this house I got three Mansions
of my own I appreciated that he changed
the narrative on people jealous on my
name and making hate on my name because
he had to say that they get people like
whoa whoa whoa this guy is actually a
good person he's staying with Tom Brady
but that don't stop then that you hate
on my name right now God is suing me god
named Ryan whatever blame this guy give
a million deals and contracts now this
guy could just you know the Public Image
you can just say anything they say
anything on my name and there's no you
know it's misinformed you know what I
mean it's uninformed it's no educated no
nothing behind it and when it happened
people just move on no one apologized no
one said they made a mistake they just
let it linger out there and you know
ruin my name man my name is more than
silver and gold so as I had a point
where it's like hey do I gotta get
disrespect to get some respect
why is Julio Jones getting paid 10
million did you see how many what's his
stack can we look that up look up his
stats look how many games he played if a
b not playing what do you think they
saying Paul Pete what do you think they
say if I don't play
hola Julio Jones stats of course put on
he's even playing
zoom in exactly check his Stacks last
year and check what I got but Tom
Brady's my boy right he cares about me
why am I paying this trainer a hundred
thousand dollars when his trainer get
paid for the Tampa Bay Bucks who's that
the Alex Guerrero guys yeah why am I
paying him a hundred thousand what's
that guy's story he's a Tom Brady
following guy I guess that's his new
wife or some [ __ ] this guy is taking
imagine that P imagine that I come to
help you out and Mike trainer is taking
a hundred thousand dollars from you
you see what I'm saying so when you go
through these things and people treat
you this way and it's over and over and
over
imagine I didn't walk off the field you
know what I'm saying because I walked
out for my respect man and also for my
health
this guy told me imagine the coach said
hey man get the [ __ ] out of here man
you've been at work what is your
mentality when you go to war P what's
your middle fortitude when you out there
on the children line this this is just
made me understand your mental fortitude
when you out there on the gun line in
the Warfare
what's your mentality
as a receiver I got to be ruthless
aggressive and decisive but calm I got
guys in my face all day they pushing the
safety over they pushing they're hitting
I got to be ruthless decisive and
aggressive but under control so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]